hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
excellent game to share with you from
the 2023 fide World Cup
I think you need your strategic cap on
for this one
on the wide end Magnus Carlson
and he's playing against nihad abisov
okay we have a Sicilian Defense
russellimo attack
an early imbalance with the minor pieces
and structure
after D6 what move would you play here
feel free to pause the video
okay in the game it's E5
excellent move
we're gonna have a closer look at what
many of the points are behind this
Advanced soon enough but first
let me just note that if you do not play
E5 and instead approach this
in a bit of a slower way
you can easily end up worse
what am I talking about well let's say
you castle and move upon and develop a
knight
black is already for choice
excellent Pawn break good news for Rook
once on the f file good news as well for
the light Square Bishop to break down
pawns that are unlike
the light Square Bishop in this
environment in this structure will have
no problem playing a productive role
compare that with what happens in the
game pay special attention to
the light Square Bishop in this game
we continue with E5 D takes E5 white has
already gained a little something
doubled and now isolated C pawns white
has no interest with his play in this
game to Simply recapture the pawn
he has a deeper idea in mind in this
game he goes with D3
let's have a look at though what could
happen after Knight takes E5
sharp position to be sure this is
considered one of the best follow-ups
these are a couple replies let's just go
with this one it's a messy position but
at least balanced material wise at the
moment
additionally here is a way black can go
wrong
this last move I think May tempt a lot
of players to go with Queen D4 seems
like black is winning not the case
though
it's a sneaky Queen trap after Queen
takes Rook Knight C3 she's stuck
officially a cornered Queen
there's no way out these two keep her in
and white just needs to clear out some
pieces something like this
and she will soon have to give herself
up
for
a rook
and in this imbalanced position queen
versus two Rooks white is for choice
okay Carlson's play is with D3
this reminds me a lot of the games by
Alpha zero
Leela Chessa zero this deep strategic
idea to give away a pun
for what reason well in large part in
this position
to play against a piece a certain piece
the light Square Bishop
we saw this time and time again with
Alpha zero games Leela chess zero games
a little material is given up and then
some piece was embarrassed its Mobility
was significantly restricted that's
what's Happening Here
the pawn has been given up in that
earlier variation the e-pawn was able to
advance but not here on its current
diagonal
staring at upon not productive you're
going to go to the main diagonal same
story you're gonna go here I'm not sure
what exactly you're doing on that
diagonal either
at some point you could be biting on a
rock Pond could be established on c for
this light Square Bishop is a struggling
piece and in a way
the black king as well has a bit of a
question mark over his head
is Queen side castles now a comfortable
safe haven for the king with these pawns
doubled and isolated
both flanks for the white Kings seem
perfectly reasonable still in this
position
okay let's see how play develops in
short with D3 white is giving up a pawn
but saying your light Square Bishop is a
clown now
we continue F6 Knight B to D2 white has
a close eye here
on two Pawn breaks there is a difference
here with move order
if the Knight is not put here straight
away but instead let's say white fee and
ketos this is where black could say you
know what I'm gonna get this Pawn out of
the way
to damage your structure I'm going to
give that pawn right back
so that I could eventually move this guy
and have a clear view for my light
Square Bishop
so
Knight B to D2 now if you try and Pitch
this Pawn the Knight can simply
recapture excellent post for the Knight
and the structure stays cool
all right
in this game Knight H6
Rook G1 this doesn't have a name this
particular variation
but
it reminds me of the move out of the
Sicilian nidorf
after black goes with A6 In the Sicilian
night orph Rook G1 has a name it's
called the freak attack okay
white is looking to advance this G Pawn
when you see Rook G1 you know it's
coming
this Pawn is ready to be launched he has
an eye on cracking open the G file
potentially
he's also going all in
he's saying all right I'm not going to
Castle kingside so I have my eye more so
on Queen side castles if you're playing
Ripta G1
he's trying to expedite this Pawn play
you could support it you could support
G4 by going H3 you know you just go one
step with the pawn but no Rook G1 he
wants to go two with the G pawn and if
necessary he's gonna go two with the H
Pawn so he could try to get in G5 he's
going all in he's kind of saying you're
not going to feel so comfortable King if
you hang him right and I already know
you're not going to feel super
comfortable castling Queen side because
of these isolated pawns everywhere
okay
Where Do We Go From Here Bishop A6 now a
lot of time was spent on this one this
was the main thing here by black at this
stage in the game
uh what is considered best instead of
Bishop to A6 the computer likes Queen to
A5 and I'd like to throw this position
to you as a pop quiz
what move would you play here
feel free to pause the video
okay the computer suggestion is to play
King F1
why
why is the computer going with Kingda F1
well let's test out a different move to
maybe get a better understanding let's
say you develop a new piece
this is where black could not only give
the pawn back but play position uh in
Gambit style you could give two pawns
back in order to damage White's
structure and activate the Clown
here with C4 the Knight is pinned after
Queen A5 there is no Knight takes C4
here
B take C
E4 the Knight can't recapture again
D takes E4
black is now up a pawn but guess what
this epon gets to move and this bishop
wants a clown is now a star piece on E6
what is it not doing perfect peace the
unopposed light Square Bishop on E6 this
needs to be taken into account this is
part of the reason why or the main
reason why
after this best move Queen A6 the
computer wants to get out of this pin
wants to be in a spot to meet C4 now
with Knight takes C4
okay
in this game it is Bishop A6
from here G4
consistent follow-up after Rook G1
Knight F7 Queen E2 yet again still not
going with Bishop to G Bishop 2 B2
Queen has an eye on these two Pawn
breaks still
Bishop E7 Bishop B2 now
Queen A5
C4 so
the computer's pointing out you could
already rush in with G5 but
now that this Knight is pinned his reply
C4 he is just shutting down this light
Square Bishop he's not giving black
an opportunity to play C4 in this
position
this remains a struggling piece
all right from here it's G5 H4
need to support G5 if you have to take
away from the center forget about it
your Central Point E5 collapses the game
is going to be over
you must be in a spot to take towards
the center
okay The Rook comes back over mission
accomplished he got that G4 advance in
he's in a favorable position here when
we consider these two Rooks it's white
who decides when the position opens when
the H file opens
Queen side castles
met with Queen side castles so white is
offering up now
a second Pawn
that would be poison
white went into a pretty big thinking
here uh
he had a big thing here about 20
20 plus minutes
taking the pawn is not a good idea it
would be a losing move Queen takes a
King C2 is threatening to trap the queen
and she'd have to run away
this is not a good Pawn to take a new
file has opened up towards the king
there's ideas for maybe a skewer
A2 in short is poison so
Queen simply goes back
Knight improves
G takes H4 Knight takes H4
where do we go from here
the idea
is to try and break this position open
white knows long term that his King is
safer
he has this nice structure if we do the
comparison on the queen with the queen
side structures
Pawn island of four
and we have all isolated pawns for the
black king
how can we maybe try to find a way in
let's try and blast open the center in
some way here it goes F4 upon break is
in there white wants at
F6 throughout all of this complications
in the center guess who's not playing
who's not a contributor
this guy here tamed by the structure
alone
from here e takes F4 Knight takes F6
we're not immediately recapturing we can
take E6 with check
and then recapture
there's no E6 Pawn anymore so now at
least this guy has a path back into
activity he has to First under develop
Bishop C8
Rook D to E1
Queen takes F Rook takes G very sharp
position I believe right around here
it's
basically a rapid time control
Queen D2 Knight is improving King C2
I thought there might be a trick here
for black it's not working though
if you're thinking in this position
about Rook takes Knight
preparing to meet Rook takes Rook with
this massive Fork
that would not be good
to play Rook takes Knight in this
position because of First bishop takes
Knight
and then you recapture and you're just
up the exchange
okay so this is not working
black goes with King B7 probably the
better color Square to be on with this
guy around
from here Rook E3
Queen E7 Knight F5 we're going to get a
minor piece Exchange in and a pair of
Rooks come off this is around an even
position
have to do something about the bishop
it's defended
this is where White NOW goes wrong
he puts the queen on H2
so he spent about nine minutes on this
move and blacks reply
spent about a minute
he ends up playing Rook to G6
there is one winning move here for black
I wonder if you can spot it
feel free to pause the video
okay not easy to come up with
uh these only winning moves in an open
position like this but the best move
is Queen to F1
and now white is kind of all pinned up
uh what do you do exactly this guy
can't move
any move by the bishop and there's going
to be this Fork
you can't take this Pawn
because after Rook takes Rook Queen
takes Rook there's going to be this Fork
so white is in a really tough spot if
black would have spotted Queen to F1
not sure how to even proceed here if
there's some passing move if white just
sits here's how black can play Rook G6
now
hinting at Rook G2 or even Rook G1 black
is getting at the white king first even
though there is this safer shelter for
the white king each side is trying to
angle in to
the king positions
black would have got there first if he
found King excuse me Queen F1 here in
this game though it's Rook G6
Bishop cuts off the queen from seeing a
couple squares she can now not get to F1
Rook F6 Bishop E3 with an eye on C5 with
an ion
the second rank as well the C5 Pawn is
going to fall two attackers no Defenders
okay from here Bishop F5 that's
move 36 the first active move
for the light Square Bishop
better late than never it's final
activated this is still considered a
holdable
position here
okay we have Bishop takes C5
Queen G6 this is where I mean both
players are kind of going back and forth
the evaluation up and down they are in
Blitz mode at this stage
okay and this game is King C3
Rook E6
Rook H4 it says in this position you
could already go in for a sneaky tactic
Bishop takes A7 with the idea King takes
Bishop being met with Rook excuse me
Queen F2 check and then the queen and
Rook are on F5 that's how you get the
material back and then you're ready to
get to the seventh rank
in this game though The Rook backs off
first
there's no longer pressure
Bishop to G4 now he goes in for this
capture on A7 considered better is the
centralization of the queen
black has one way out after this move
Bishop takes A7 but he does not find it
in the game Queen F6 check is played
considered best is Queen G7 check still
keeping a close eye on the bishop that's
one note and another is keeping a close
eye on the seventh rank in particular
this C7 Square in some cases the queen
can pivot there
so let's have a look at this best line
this is a really interesting variation
Queen G7 the only drawing move
why well if you block with the bishop
there's some Queen G5 exerting pressure
on The Rook eyeing up a check on not
only C1 but also A5
also if you go to B4 check this
variation now this is one of the coolest
variations I think you'll see
let's see why I'm pointing that out why
I'm saying that King takes Bishop here
you're ready for these next four half
moves
every one of them is check
Queen G1 in this continuation I'm
pointing out is considered is leading to
a drawn position here we go Queen G1
check
would be met with C5 check would be met
with Queen C5 check
and then met with Rook B6 check I don't
know how many more moves there are like
that in the game consecutive checks but
Foreigner four in a row four half moves
all with check here apparently after
King A3 this is some drawn position
all right I had to highlight that
continuation
extremely rare
drawn position from here
in this game though Queen F6 is played
so
the King has to find a square of course
the queen does not have defense of the
bishop in this case so the king could
now step up to B four
in the game it's Rook E5 if the bishop
is captured here this is where we could
see the big difference between Queen on
G7 versus F6
in this position the queen could now
make use of C7 with check
and then simply take the bishop she's
not defending the bishop as well
from here well in this position white is
winning next up getting to the eighth
rank or seventh rank
okay
in this game The Rook goes to E5
this Rook is now pinned I should have
noted this earlier there is a serious
threat
after Bishop takes A7 the threat being
Queen B8 check King A6 and queen B6 mate
so we're simply with D4 attacking a
pinned piece
from here Queen E7 check only one more
move C5
black resigns there are no good
follow-up checks if the king takes the
bishop we take the Rook with the pawn
not the queen because she has this
responsibility to defend the Rook
and what else do you do
any move by The Rook and it's a mate in
two
for instance Rook E4
there's our mate in two
in action so at the end of the day white
in this position is simply soon going to
be up material it goes no further
black resigns
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
I hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye
foreign
foreign foreign